dimanche matin. Une cinquantaine
de personnes sont rassemblées
pour parler de profilage racial,
quelques jours après
l'arrestation d'un homme noir
menotté sans motif c'est un  c'e
de respect!
- En toile de fond dea décision
de la Cour supérieureinterdisans
de procéder à l'interception
de véhicules sans T,
premier ministre du Québec
- C'est jugement qui est long,
qui doit être analysé.
Donc, on va prendrlyser.
- Québec n'a toujours pas fait
savoir s'il allait faire appel
de la décision du juge.
... a inle Cabinet du ministre
... a indiqué dimanche
le Cabinet du ministre
de la Justice.
- Bien que la section demptes...
- L'ex-policier Alain Babineaust
contestée.
ALAIN BABINEAU, an du Canada
- Parce que ça a une influence
sur le travail policier
à la grandeur du Canada,
c'est pauve que c'est
une excellente décision.
- Ce professeur de criminologie
a consacré les 15 dernières
des policiers. Selon lui,
l'article 636 du Code de la
sécurité routière, qui permet
les interpellations aléatoires,
le profilage racial.
MASSIMILIANO MULONE, prof.
agrégé, École de crimino., UdeM
- La décision du juge Yergeau,
qui, malheureusement, produit
beaucoup de discri
raciale.
- Une opinion qui n'est pas
des directeurs de police,
qui estidécisiondécisiondécision
du juge aura des répercussions
sur la sécurité routière.
d'interpellations aléatoires,
il faut  qu'il faut
laisser les policiers faire
leur travail.
- Le juge Yergeau explique
clairement que, un, la décision
n'affecte en rien les barrages
- En 2019, une étude démontrait
que les personnes autochtone
et noires ont entre quatre
d'être interpellées par rapport
aux personnes blan
- On peut pas juste se
contenter, même si c'est
une chose importante, de tabler
sur la formation, la lente
Il faut aussi agir sur
les prat
- Ici Hadi Hassin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.